But, hang on,
aren't we part of the Earth?
We're organic creatures,
made of the same molecules
as everything else on our planet -
one interconnected ecosystem
that keeps us all alive.
But are we superior?
Different? Or special?
Why do we so often feel, well...
separate from the Earth?
In fact, not everyone does.
Throughout human history
lots of cultures have viewed
their relationship to
the Earth in other ways.
Many still do.
Animism - the belief that
spirit infuses objects,
nature and the whole of existence -
is a fundamental principle
of many indigenous societies.
In Taoism, cosmic energy -
or life force - is everywhere
and is constantly seeking harmony
and balance between all things.
Ancient Andean civilisations
placed the spirit of Pachamama,
or Mother Earth, at the very centre
of their worldview.
And, today, for many indigenous
people of the world,
like the U'wa tribe in Colombia,
the Earth is not just the dust
from which human beings are made,
it's the spirit of their people
and ancestors.
It's their history.
It is life itself.
This isn't always an easy idea
for people in today's
Western societies to grasp.
The Druids of Ancient Britain
did grasp it -
focusing their spiritual practices
on a reverence
and connection with nature.
But when Christianity
spread through Europe,
animism was condemned
as pagan and savage.
European colonialism enforced
these views around the globe,
in places like
the Americas and Australia -
crushing the indigenous peoples
and their nature wisdom.
Since the birth of agriculture,
humans had been manipulating
the world around them,
harnessing, dividing
and selling its natural resources.
But under colonization,
the Earth became a place to be
conquered, dominated,
farmed, fished, plundered
and mined, on a vast scale.
Was there any scientific thinking
behind our ever-increasing
control over the natural world?
17th Century Europe thought so.
In fact thought was
all the rage then,
as French philosopher
Rene Descartes,
and other others,
like Sir Isaac Newton,
helped to kick off
the Enlightenment -
an era that prized reasoning,
science and order.
A new view of the world emerged -
with human beings as
the thinking, rational, masters,
and nature as our unthinking,
unfeeling servant.
Standing apart from her,
humans investigated nature's
ultimate questions,
dissecting her into smaller
and smaller pieces.
This brought us great power.
And with great power, comes...
... you know the rest.
The Anthropocene Age had begun -
an epoch defined by
one dominant species.
Us.
On a planet that is billions
of years old, in just 500 years,
much of the human race
has come to see itself
as the rulers
and center of all life.
Today, we are still trying to bend
the planet's environment,
processes and biodiversity
to our will.
Our vast, sprawling cities
have pushed nature
out of sight and out of mind.
The world is attempting to meet the
urgent challenge of climate change.
But can anything fundamentally change
while we still see ourselves
as somehow separate from Earth?
There are signs of hope. Other voices
are starting to be heard once again.
Influenced by a resurgent
indigenous view of Pachamama,
Bolivia and Ecuador have passed
laws granting all nature
equal rights with humans.
And in New Zealand,
a Maori tribe has successfully fought
to have their river -
and ancestor -
given the same legal rights
as a person.
In an interconnected world,
can we humans find ways to truly
reconnect to all life on the planet?
A new era might start
with one single idea.
There is no Earth and us.
We are one.